if there is any difference between us
and the animals it is the obligation to
this form of planetary wholeness through
wholeness of self and wholeness of every
atom of human organization through the
couple the infinity group the tribe the
larger context of one's friends and
acquaintances and the new age has the
rhetoric of collectivity in the same way
that the the psychedelic generation of
the 60s had the rhetoric of collectivity
but in each case it was vitiated
by various factors which tended to
inject masculine values into the context
that was evolving G K Chesterton said
men are men but man is a woman and the
problem has been that we have been run
by little man in other words that small
people who bought into the idea that
ideas should rule have been at the
tiller of history for a very long time
the goddess which is this hidden notion
that men are men but man is a woman the
goddess has been completely suppressed
now most embryologists would probably
agree with the statement that men are
far more lean modified female fetuses
and human civilization is a hormonal II
mana [ __ ] modified corpus delicti if you
wish and the hormonal modification is
for purposes of transcendence which once
achieved that the historical model of
human beings will be useless I'm sure
you know the faith or the story or the
folklore about how when buddha trust the
river of enlightenment in the bows of
the dharma when he reached the other
side someone said what are you going to
do with your bows and he said well now
that I'm on the other side I have no
need of it and this is I think how we
need to think of the patriarchal linear
uniform culture it created a context for
saving the entire biosphere now the
entire biosphere can be saved only
through the transcendence of that
previous context so it is it is very
important to for those people who are
interested in suicide to go deeper into
it and try to language the previously on
language feeling because you see the
feeling is not in principle on language
of
it's simply that it no utility accrued
to it in the mail constellated value
system once we understand now that it is
that the the evolution of communication
now depends on the evolution of a
language of emotion we can see that the
evolution of a language of emotion is
the primary task of of psychedelic users
and the using of that language of
emotion to communicate and to bootstrap
ourselves to higher and higher levels of
caring this will all happen within the
context of the project caring for being
which is which was heidegger's
formulation for what life is all about
and I have not ran tied to here on
arrows but I do believe that era of the
project of caring for being cannot -
cannot be divided apart now I want to
close by reading a brief quote from
Jacob Needleman but very
synchronistically cab discovery just a
few minutes before we left the house
today
the impact of Socrates is to produce
upon a human being a specific sort of
suffering that involves seeing oneself
against a very high criterion of what
human being should be but this seeing of
oneself is not a moralistic effort to
persuade one's self to do better on the
contrary its effect is to Kindle eros
are longing for being the impact of
Socratic interrogation which is
objective self interrogation is the
suffering that results from the repeated
and prolonged confrontation in oneself
between what is meant to be between what
one is meant to be and what one is until
a human being passes through this fire
all of his efforts and virtue will fade
and I think there is no more intense way
to pass through that fire than with the
psychedelic experience I've always
assumed with the chain that the sign of
the psychedelic experience was leave the
clinging flame and I think to pass
through that clinging flame is to
discover this context of what we may be
as opposed to what we are what I really
hoped and imagined is happening is that
a true a true a marquise might be
possible through the cultivation of
responsibility not out of intellectual
appreciation of the need to do that but
out of the more natural and spontaneous
and visceral need to do that which
arises quite spontaneously in other
words Anarchy can never be erected on a
substratum of theoretical considerations
has to be erected on a substratum of
very intense realized feelings and this
is what things like the nuclear freeze
and the whole liberal agitation for
global consciousness of global problems
is about realizing the responsibility of
that we all share toward each other and
then you know feeding people in the
world who are hungry curing diseases and
portions of the area of the world where
diseases are endemic these will not be
great philanthropic undertakings they
will be things seem to be as natural and
necessary as caring for your own
backyard and the psychedelics promote
this because they show the commonality
of being they make you feel the family
of human beings rather than
theoretically understand it the other
Forks which will create this NRP of
responsibility is the evolution of
language which I mentioned in the
lecture someone asked me more what I
meant about that whether I meant simply
new words or new feelings which is
certainly part of it and and much of
what's gone on in California in the past
10 years in terms of vocabulary
construction has been put down as
psychobabble but remember the less there
is a useful residual in that and that
will stay in the language more than that
I can imagine ontological
transformations of language so that we
can actually show each other our
thoughts by create by discovering
proto-language Azure assembly languages
in the human organization that do not
require a culturally validated
dictionary to be understood in other
words but things like chanting and
toning and that sort of thing they do
convey emotions but very generalized
emotions because at this stage of
evolution of argyll camp of our
emotional vocabularies all emotions are
generalized emotions but eventually this
might be refined to a very high state I
mean our great great artists are capable
of this I know I can remember when I
first read the remembrance of things
past by Marcel Proust there are a number
of places in there where you realize
with a real sense of shock that you have
never even articulated to yourself this
feeling let alone ever attempted to
articulate it to another person because
it seems so personal and non
generalizable that you thought it was
uniquely yourself and you have here it
is on the printed page and we need more
of this because seeing that emotion
portrayed on the printed page I have an
immense sense of revalidation of my own
experience of it and there are many many
emotions like this I remember
particularly in incidents in the
remembrance of things past where the
narrator whose name
forget is riding in a carriage to a very
elegant party with this ancient
crumbling Contessa who is the matron of
the Society of the rude to some chairman
and she's prattling on about something
someone's love affair someone's jewelry
something and they pass a certain group
of trees which this the narrative
glimpses at the window and he feels this
immense desire to stop the carriage and
to go over and look at the trees for no
reason at all and yet he feels that some
kind of immense choice is being made and
that if he doesn't stop the carriage his
life will be irrevocably different and
that something very precious will be
lost and never regained and meantime
he's trying to maintain in this intense
formal social situation and he does
nothing and the moment passes and is
forgotten by him I'm sure but you
participated and say you know I felt
like that I wanted to do that and it
seemed so so irrational so obscure so
caught up in the processes of my own
becoming that I would never even mention
or disagree to someone here it is
validated as a general experience of
human beings and we need to do this for
each other a lot I'm very shocked to
realize how much communication goes on
that is not direct communicate
between human beings how much reading
listening watching how how rarely there
is actually one-to-one conversation
between human beings and yet that is
where the the progress really takes
place but we undervalue it we don't even
notice that it's being taken away from
us and the media and packaged
interaction is replacing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]